let's make these crispy waffle maker
hash browns we're going to start by
peeling our potatoes I'm using three
large russet potatoes here but if you
want to use a different kind of potato
feel free to use your favorite then
we're going to shred our potatoes we're
doing a fine shred here soak the
potatoes in cold water for about 30
minutes to remove the excess starch now
we're going to drain that excess
moisture using a cheesecloth let's add
in the toppings I'm using cheddar
chopped ham melted butter pepper and
garlic salt give that a good mix and
it's time to cook add a bit of oil to
your waffle maker and a heaping half cup
of your hash brown mixture let it cook
for at least five minutes to make sure
the potatoes are fully cooked and then
take it out whenever you reach your
perfect doneness I like mine extra
crispy so I left them in a little longer
okay I have hash browns without ketchup
it's so crispy and delicious put in your
favorites toppings you got yourself a
solid breakfast snack make a breakfast
Burger use these as buns put a sausage
patty an egg inside bacon